Hi, I'm Tom from the Portswigger development team. Today I'm going to show you how easy it is to
leverage Burp AI in your Burp Suite extensions using the Montoya API. To do this, I'm going to
be working through a live example of how to integrate AI in the reporting extension that
I've been writing. So I've done all of the fun swing UI part here to save you having to watch
me fumble with that bit. We have issues, we can add some custom requirements for our report, and we
can hit generate. But the report generation isn't yet implemented, so I'm going to show you how to do
that now. So if we hop into our code, you can see that we've got this report generation class here.
The first thing this does when it generates a report is it checks whether AI is enabled. AI can be turned
off or on for extensions individually. So it's important in your extension before doing any AI
operations to check whether it's enabled, otherwise it's not going to work. The second important thing
we do is we move off of the swing thread onto a new thread, because what we're going to be doing with AI
could take a long time and we don't want to hinder the user experience as it runs. So I've just got a
little utility here I wrote that creates a service and runs any code that you give it. I've also made
sure that my extension shuts down the executor service when it's done. So once we hopped onto a new
thread, I've got some boilerplate here that's just generating a report class, executing the prompt,
which is not yet implemented, rendering it to HTML, and then saving it. The reason that we're rendering to
HTML here is that if we ask the AI to respond in HTML, it's not always going to do an amazing job. It's going
to tend to, it prefers to respond in Markdown. So it's better to just let it do that and then do the
conversion ourselves. The reason I even need to do the conversion is just because swing components
can render HTML and they can't render Markdown. Otherwise it would probably would have just left
it in Markdown. So how do we actually execute our prompt? Well, the first thing we need to do is we
need to create some messages. A message is a what we actually send to the AI and there are three different
types. There are system messages, user messages and assistant messages. The first thing we're going to want
is a system message. So if we create a new message for system message and a Montoya helper for this and
we're going to give it our content. Now I've already written out the system message so you don't have to see me
get it wrong several times with typos and all that. But what we're effectively doing is we're
explaining to the AI the role that we want it to provide. So we're telling it that it is a DAST
vulnerability report writer. We're going to tell it the input we're going to give it. So a series of
web application vulnerabilities found by Burp Suite's DAST scanner and a set of custom requirements
given by the user. We're then explaining what its task is, which is to generate a vulnerability report.
We're going to give it some parameters to work in. So we're going to tell it to be clear and readable,
detailed, comprehensive, where possible. We want it to retain the original wording in the issues.
We need it to retain or include all of the additional information requested by the client
and also include any additional information it thinks is relevant. What we're also doing is rather
than sending the issue evidence or the request responses to the AI for it to include, we're just
going to tell it how to attach them. This is because we want to limit the data that we're sending
and receiving from the AI. Each token that we send is effectively going to, so we don't want to send
things that are unnecessary. In this case it doesn't need the evidence to construct the report so we can
just tell it how to embed it and we'll do that afterwards. So we want to put our system message
into our first message and we'll create a new list to put our messages in.
And we'll put generics on it because that's how you write good java code.
Yep, so messages add system message. So what we want to do next is actually send our content.
So we're going to create a message for our custom requirements and this is going to be a user message.
So this is data that the user is sending. We've set up our system message so we now want to provide
user data and again there's a nice Montoya help for creating a user message. Now we're not just going
to paste the custom requirements straight in because we do want to give the AI a little bit of context as
to what data we're providing here and this really just has to take the form of custom requirements
and then we'll add the custom requirements and that's as easy as that. So we'll add that to our
messages. So what we want to do now and Copilot is handily giving us a hint is to create a user
message for each of the issues that we want to send. So yeah we'll hit the right button. So for each
issue we want to generate a new message and add it to our messages. Now obviously this issue message
doesn't exist that's not a thing in the Montoya API because that's a custom requirement we have,
not a general use case. So we're going to create user messages but I will go ahead and create a little
helper here for creating a issue message and that will take an issue, an audit issue. So what we want
to do here is effectively serialize issue data. So we'll create the issue and we want an issue type
which will be the issue type as you'd expect. We want the issue severity. You're going to see me fumble
with the keyboard a lot here. We want the confidence. Okay Copilot's getting the hang of this now. We want
the issue URL. I spoke too soon. We want the detail. We want the background.
We want the remediation if I can spell it. And we want the number of evidence items. Like I said
we're not going to actually attach the evidence. We're just going to tell the AI how many there are
so that it can kind of use that information. So we're going to format this with the issue type
which I think is the name. I've called it type but it is actually name on the interface.
There's a severity. There's a confidence. There's a base URL. There's a detail. There's a background.
There is a remediation. Is that next? Yep remediation. And then for the evidence we want to get the request
responses and just get the size. Cool. So we're going to return that and format it a bit better as well.
Don't know where that came from. Don't need that. Cool. So yep we are now serializing our issues into
something that the AI can understand. Again using kind of the minimal amount of data that we want to
send to actually get the value that we need. So we've got all of our messages. What do we need to do now?
So now we actually need to again copilot's jumping the gun again a bit but we want to actually
execute our prompt. So we're going to create a new prompt object using the Montoya API's AI object
and then we're going to execute it sending our messages. We can also provide prompt options here
and that allows us to control the temperature of our request. The temperature is a float value between
zero and two where the closer it gets to two the more creative the AI gets. The default value is 0.5
which is a little bit creative but mostly sticking to kind of facts and not trying to think outside
the box too much which is about right for what we want. So I'm just going to leave it as it is.
So this will go and execute our prompt or our series of messages as a prompt and then we can just
get the content which is the result. The final thing we want to do here is we want to make sure that we've
got any error handling covered. So we are going to catch any prompt exceptions that can happen.
Now this could be due to the AI being unreachable. It could be because the AI is disabled. It could be
that we run out of credits. For now all that we're going to do is we're going to log these to error.
And again this is just a little utility that I've written that wraps the Montoya logging API so that I can
do it statically. And for now we'll just return just an empty string because it's just the easiest way
to do for our little example here. I was wondering why that was complaining. Again generics because I'm
trying to code live and remember how to do it. So just to summarize what we're doing is we are taking
our system message which is our instructions for how the AI should behave. We're taking user messages which
are an approximation for our input where each message is wrapping the input in a bit of context
and then we're sending all of those to the AI making sure to account for any errors.
So let's build that again and hop back in. So we'll go and reload our extension. Make sure the AI is
turned on and send some issues. Cool. So we're going to hit generate report now and that's going to go off
again on a new thread as we did and send our messages to the AI and we'll see what it comes back with.
All of this code will be available in the extensions repository. I've created a branch specifically for
this code demo. So the code in the live version of the extension is a little different because there
are different generation modes I've added and slightly more robust error handling. But there is a branch
specifically for this code with me demo if you want to go and check out the code that's been written.
That will be committed there.
There we go. So we can see that we have generated a vulnerability report for Gin and Juice Shop. We've got all of
our issues in here with all of the data that we sent and a summary at the end. Now what I probably should
have done is give it some custom requirements to show the actual value of doing this rather than just
formatting what comes directly out of Burp's issues. But never mind. I'm not going to run it again and make
everyone sit and watch that. But yeah, there we go. That was how easy it was to take all of our data from
our extension and use Burp AI to create a powerful response. I don't know how to end this so just give
it a go yourselves, I guess. It's that easy.